the jurogan experience do you think you
could still throw down
like if it had to happen like if jake
paul called you out
he probably [ __ ] me up really good
boxer he's a good boxer what if it was
kickboxing he doesn't really know how to
kick
a younger man and i had good knees i
could be kickboxing people but
i could barely get through a workout
without being in pain now there's a
reality of
knees and backs have you tried the pvc
peptide
it helps you maintain but there's a big
difference between maintaining and
working out and then
getting being able to train for a fight
yeah so you think
being able to train for a fight your
body would break down yeah yeah
yeah jake is interesting man he is
excellent at trump's
brother yeah his brother's there's a we
played a video of his brother
wrestling uh paulo costa yeah yeah his
brother is [ __ ] legit
i think he's a legit athlete yeah i
think he wrestled back in the day yeah
yeah he did yeah wrestling college jamie
tried to shut it down and say it was
like junior college
and it's actually real college that's
that ohio rivalry right there that's
what that is
no let's go listen man you got to give
credit where credit's due yeah i know
those guys like to troll
but he's jake and his brother are both
legitimate tough guys they're tough do
you think that
you need trolling now for fight sports
are we at a point where like that's the
only thing that engages the casual fan
well khabib nurmagomedov is the biggest
draw in combat sports
and he doesn't do any trash talk but is
that a reflection of dominance
it's like are we kind of watching to see
if he'll lose like the mayweather effect
well like how many people are rooting
for like khabib seems like incredibly
like sweet guy and he's like a
consummate
professional but i feel like the way you
market the fight is
not in the way that when we were younger
watching roy jones we're like yo roy
just going to do some crazy thing where
like
puts his hand behind his back and just
knocks the dude out like we're rooting
for roy to win leaving his most dominant
time
i feel like now the way you promote the
fight is oh this is the perfect guy to
take out khabib
you know like justin's the perfect oh
yeah you know he's got striking but he
has a wrestling background we're kind of
like thinking of different ways we take
him down
where it's like yeah i don't know i
don't know if like i don't know if we're
if we're if we're rooting for him to win
in that way um well if you're a fan of
his you're rooting for him to win sure
and i'm sure
he's from that kind of when you have a
guy who's khabib's
28 or 29-0 and really smashed everybody
in front of them yeah you always wonder
like who's going to be the guy that
solves that riddle yeah
and justin came real close with those
leg kicks yeah he was
he was really [ __ ] up his leg yeah
and but khabib figured out a way to get
the fight to the ground
almost finished at the beginning or the
end rather of the first round
and then got him in the second round
yeah he's just he's on another level
yeah and that's one of the things that
happens when you're i mean you got to
realize that guy is supremely
disciplined
yeah supremely dedicated like doesn't
drink doesn't smoke doesn't [ __ ] around
doesn't abuse his body
always fit always in shape always
training and lives like a champion
and it's like very religious like very
devout muslim
like doesn't i think that doesn't [ __ ]
oh yeah
he's not partying he's not doing coke
and banging hoes there's none of that
he's just smashing people yeah you know
but i think he's
they're trying to talk him into having
more fights right he told his mother
that he was going to retire
after he fought gaichi yeah i remember
seeing that but you know what man he's
in his prime
and you only get one prime yeah and you
know and as
what more can you the most dominant man
in the sport
yeah what's going on here that weight
cut he had there it was uh going around
again from his
oh wow his last fight oh he always cuts
a lot of weight but it was they're
apparently very brutal yeah it's brutal
but what more can he do
he's not really 155 pounds
there's a thing in in mixed martial arts
that we all just accept
and it's it's a sanctioned form of
cheating like you're pretending you're
155 pounds so you
draw your body out you dry out to 155
and then you [ __ ] balloon back up
eat a lot of spaghetti and balloon back
up to 200 pounds after the weight cut
yeah that's nuts
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience